[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
virginie calmels ce vice présidente des
républicains est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir annoncé michèle rota
et merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation donc au nom de public sénat
des échos de radio classique et de la
lfp de médias représentés ce soir par
charlotte bottier et paul briat bonsoir
à tous deux bonsoir
virginie calmels ce 3 questions pour
vous ce soir d'abord bien sûr
manquez-vous de solidarité avec laurent
wauquiez puisque leurs proches vous
effet depuis ce week-end deuxièmement
quelle stratégie pour les républicains
aux européennes aux éau municipal pour
que votre parti retrouve sa base
électorale
enfin troisième question emmanuel macron
président de droite puisque c'est comme
ça qu'il est majoritairement perçu y
compris d'ailleurs dans votre camp mais
d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
le navire humanitaire l'aquarius avec
ses 6 129 migrants à bord pourra être
accueillis par l'espagne qui se dit
prête effectivement à l'accueillir après
le refus de l'italie et de malte
également est ce que c'est un
soulagement pour vous quelles facs coup
dur on ne peut pas être indifférent à la
détresse humaine et des bateaux qui donc
ont des migrants à bord ce sont des
personnes qui sont en détresse donc il
est évident qu'il faut régler les
problèmes aujourd'hui la question la
question de l'accueil est une autre
c'est déjà réglé les problèmes réglés
les problèmes c'est se rendre compte
qu'on va être face à une pression et un
défi migratoire qu'il va être croissant
d'ailleurs on l'a vu en italie
malheureusement ça a entraîné les
populistes au pouvoir avec cette
alliance de la ligue et du mouvement 5
étoiles et c'est pour ça que je crois
urgent que en france nous nous ayons des
réponses très concrètes très pragmatique
mais aussi humaniste évidemment aux
problématiques des migrants je pense que
l'espagne
effectivement apporte une solution
solution provisoire c'est à dire l'idée
c'est de ne pas laisser ce bateau
finalement refusé et à la dérive
j'ai compris que la france d aujourd hui
également ouvre un accès port par
exemple pendant dix ans que les
républicains à porte sur ce sujet
quelques quelques préconisations de
l'accueil la première c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'on doit laisser partir ces
bateaux au fond parce qu'une autre notre
le oui mais notre problème c'est de
savoir si on est en capacité
d'accueillir moi évidemment je pense que
la france doit s'enorgueillir d'être une
terre d'asile pour des gens en situation
vraiment de très grande précarité ou de
danger politique c'est ça le sens de
l'asile politique
en revanche on voit bien que
malheureusement c'est souvent dévoyée
pour créer des filières d'immigration
illégale et donc on a besoin d'apporter
des solutions concrètes en instruisant
les dossiers avant que les bateaux
n'arrivent
car on sait que malo
derrière l'expulsion de ces êtres qui
restent des êtres humains et pose
problème et donc c'est pour ça que nous
voulons traiter les sujets le plus en
amont possible avec des accords de
coopération notamment avec les pays
duquel ces migrants sont issues que vous
avez cité le pouvoir qui est en place
depuis quelques semaines en italie avec
l'extrême droite notamment représentée
par son ministre de l'intérieur matteo
salvini qui crient victoire sur twitter
puisque le bateau n'accostera pas sur
ses côtés ce qu'on peut crier victoire
selon vous quand on repousse ainsi un
bateau de migrants savez charme michel
grossiord moi je veux surtout que jamais
nous ne tombions dans cet extrémisme
dans ce populisme mais aussi dans cette
déshumanisation
évidemment qu'on a un sujet majeur une
fois encore je le répète le défi
migratoire est devant nous et il faut le
traiter et il faut le traiter avec
responsabilité
avec courage il faut pas non plus tomber
dans la main sur le coeur on accueille
tout le monde alors qu'on n'est pas en
capacité de le faire qu'on n'est pas
capable de leur offrir un travail ou un
logement décent et donc il faut plutôt
travailler en amont pour que ces flux
migratoires soit au contraire désireux
de rester dans les pays qui sont les
leurs en ayant le maximum de
développement sur place la suite tout de
suite avec charles gautier donc il vous
pose la première question de l'émission
[Musique]
alors manquer vous de solidarité avec
laurent wauquiez en critiquant la ligne
réaffirmée par le tract dont on ne cesse
de parler depuis la semaine dernière la
france pour que la france reste la
france
une droite assumé et identitaire alors
d'abord je suis pas certaine d'avoir
critiqué le tract contrairement à ce qui
est en train comme toujours de faire
flore effectivement de consultation
finalement ça sans merci mais aussi le
slogan un peu anxiogène
non si on veut pas parler du slogan que
je gêne mais j'y reviens pour être très
précis alors la première des choses
d'abord c'est qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
moi à titre personnel depuis le début
j'ai souhaité le rassemblement de notre
famille politique c'est dans ce contexte
là que j'ai accepté la proposition que
laurent wauquiez machette il est venu me
chercher en me disant qu'il voulait
qu'on fasse un tandem pour nous
présenter dans l'élection notamment à la
tête des républicains et ensuite pour
diriger ce parti avec une équipe
rajeunie renouveler paritaire et le
sentiment que le tandem là n'avaient
plus cours
avec ce tract en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que d'abord cette équipe les au
travail depuis maintenant 6 mois donc ça
reste récent et ça se met en place
j'ai simplement répondu avec tout
l'honnêteté qui me caractérise moi je ne
suis pas quelqu'un qui ment j'ai mon
franc parler je suis authentique
donc quand on me pose une question qui
est tout simplement madame calmels
avez-vous valider ce tract je réponds
tout naturellement la réalité des faits
non en ce sens je ne pense pas manquer
de solidarité parce que je crois que le
monde politique a besoin justement bas
qu'on dise les choses de façon claire et
en disant ça je n'incrimine et personne
j'ai simplement dit que ce n'était pas
le cas et que je m'étonnais que laurent
wauquiez n'est pas consulté les
instances du parti qu'il a lui même
désigné
voilà voilà ce que j'ai fait ensuite
trop c'est trop par exemple pour brice
hortefeux on va l'écouter
puisque il vous met en cause
virginie calmels savez qui a soif de
responsabilité et qui a d'ailleurs qui
est arrivé la semaine dernière elle a
maintenant une longue expérience
politique
elle sait très bien que lorsque l'on
intègre une équipe et il y a bien sûr en
tout cas à mes yeux un impératif de
solidarité pas la solidarité quand tout
va bien parce que ça c'est 13,6 alors
donc ça veut dire quoi un impératif de
solidarité quand on vous pose une
question et ça veut dire qu'il fallait
mentir en ce qui me concerne je dis les
choses telles qu'elles se sont passées
en suède argué que le tract avait été
mis sur un fou il s'assure donc la suie
destinateur d'ailleurs au courant c'est
ce qu'il dit a avoué mais c'est bien ce
que je dis moi aussi c'est que je ne
l'est pas validé en revanche est ce
qu'il ya une information oui je vous le
confirme
est ce que d'ailleurs ça m'a donné
l'occasion de réagir oui bien évidemment
est ce que j'ai fait part de mes
commentaires sur ce tract à laurent
wauquiez lui même oui mais c'était aussi
aux jeunes ce tract ans et est ce que on
en a tenu compte la réponse est non
voilà ok les gars étaient consternés par
vos critiques vous avez dit anxiogène
église dit j'étais consterné par la
critique en en
comme quoi il serait anxiogène des
strapontins il a été consternée par
toutes les critiques et on mélange un
peu tout il ya les antilles wauquiez qui
font de l'anti wauquiez primaires c'est
pas mon cas moi je suis légitimiste je
participe dans cette équipe à
rassemblement de la droite à la
reconstruction de la droite tout ce que
j'essaye de faire depuis le début c'est
d'éviter l'explosion de la droite alors
que justement nous avons des
sensibilités différentes sur le
caractère anxiogène du tract je les dis
parce que là encore j'en ai déjà fait
pas et je crois pas que ce soit manqué
de solidarité que simplement de pouvoir
avoir sa liberté de pensée c'est pour ça
qu'on est venu me chercher je n'y a pas
un mètre et une élève
il ya à mon avis des hommes et des
femmes qui normalement doivent pouvoir
dialoguer débattre je crois que c'est ça
finalement ce tract c'est un acteur
autoritaire de laurent wauquiez
d'imposer ce tract sans consultation
c'est un peu ce que vous dites mais je
vais vous dire j'ai pas envie
d'épiloguer par rapport à tout ça j'en
sais rien moi j'ai noté que c'était de
mon point de vue un dysfonctionnement
par rapport à ce que j'attends
mais vous savez monsieur hortefeux dit
que j'ai une longue expérience politique
il mena oui moi que lui ça c'est certain
mais au-delà de ça moi vous savez je
suis dans ce parti et les républicains
depuis même pas deux ans et demi j'avais
jamais été encarté auparavant pour moi
un parti politique c'est un lieu de
débats des changes de respect des
différentes sensibilités
et là j'ai simplement souligné que pour
moi c'était un dysfonctionnement comme
là où c'est intéressant c'est qu'on a
l'impression dans leur argumentation à
l'un comme à l'autre que c'est pas un
dysfonctionnement que le
dysfonctionnement c'est le fait de dire
que tient cet étonnant que les instances
ne se soit pas prononcé
nous n'avons pas la même vision je pense
une fois encore je lui dis à laurent
wauquiez qu'on est plus intelligent à
plusieurs que tout seul
j'ai noté qu' un certain nombre de
fédérations ne l'ont pas tractée et ça
veut dire que il me semble qu on aurait
pu en amont plus se concerter pour
savoir si la ligne parce que c'est une
ligne politique derrière un tract c'est
pas très grave mais il ya une ligne
politique
et quand on parle du caractère anxiogène
moi je me désolidarise pas du tout ni
des propositions je les ai soutenus je
suis pour un régalien fort je pense
qu'il faut lutter contre l'immigration
contre l'asile qui est dévoyée
et cette immigration est d'accord pour
dire que la france change de nature par
exemple dans le texte vous êtes d'accord
la france change telle de nature je vais
vous dire moi j'aime pas les raccourcis
les slogans pour que la france reste la
france
ça a été employé dans beaucoup de
discours de mitterrand à nicolas sarkozy
chaque nature certains y ont vu un clin
d'oeil au grand remplacement la thèse du
grand emplacement selon laquelle les
populations exogènes viendrait remplacer
les français est-ce que vous aussi vous
considérez que quand on dit la france
change de nature c'est pas forcément
très important une fois encore si je ne
veux pas manquer de solidarité à l'égard
de mon parti vous me permettrait de
garder mais commet pas non les jeux les
faits je pense que je les fais l'effet
vis-à-vis des personnes qui sont en
charge
je dis ce que j'avais à dire là dessus
derrière ce tract à circuler moi je
constate qu'un certain nombre de
fédérations ne l'ont pas tracter en ce
qui me concerne j'ai dit que cette page
2 du tract qui n'est pas les
propositions aussi le constat migration
voilà on signale mi août en dessous d'un
gentil c'est sur ce constat que je
trouve que c'est anxiogène et surtout
que je trouve que c'est souvent les gens
qui n'ont jamais exercé le pouvoir qui
sont dans une vision assez extrémiste et
populiste pour dire en gros regardez où
nous en sommes alors que nous n'avons
jamais exercé annoncé qu'on allait de
déchets ça c'est contre dans l'ultime ce
tract jeu je pense en tout cas que cette
page 2 de mon point de vue n'apporte pas
nécessairement grand chose surtout
contente de lier un constat de la france
avec emmanuel macron qui est au pouvoir
depuis quand même assez peu de temps je
pense que ce qui est important c'est les
propositions que les rébellions dans
l'est dans l'émission en mesure de
porter et je pense surtout que notre
famille politique elle doit avoir une
barrière étanche avec le populisme avec
l'extrémisme nous sommes un parti de
gouvernement
ce qu'on attend de nous c'est des
propositions qui soient sérieuses
travail et que nous soyons pas là pour
agiter des peurs ou de l'anxiété mais
plutôt pour répondre aux attentes
en revanche
une droite c'est à dire que moi je n'ai
pas de problème à afficher clairement on
retient la barrière aux moisissures hier
j'écoutais la barrière avec le populisme
quand on vous écoute on a l'impression
qu'elle disparaît là je vous dis ce qui
est ma vision cher michel grossiord une
droite qui osent aborder tous les sujets
qui ne s'interdit pas de parler
d'immigration de lutte contre
l'islamisme radical contre le
communautariste ou 7ème gildas je
souhaite réellement porter des
propositions concrètes
je souhaite aussi qu'on ne s'éloigne pas
de ce qui est notre combat et notamment
économiques je les dis j'ai osé dire oui
que je trouve dommage qu'on parle pas du
chômage dans ce tract s'est pas manqué
de solidarité c'est le contraire d'être
objectifs pour dire voyez tous les gens
qui souffrent et à 6 millions de
chômeurs dans notre pays on vous oublie
pas et on a des propos ici pour vous il
n'ya pas un mètre et une élève mais nous
on constate que c'est plutôt le mariage
de la carpe et du lapin
eh bien je ne le crois par michel
grossiord en tout cas moi je suis une
femme résolument de droite
j'ai toujours voté à droite j'ai soutenu
deux fois nicolas sarkozy à la
présidentielle
j'ai voté pour françois fillon parce que
pour moi c'était le meilleur projet pour
la france et je continue à défendre
cette droite ma droite c'est-à-dire qui
veut un régalien fort françois fillon
avait été très clair sur la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
surtout ce que nous ne voulons plus en
matière d'immigration incontrôlée nous
voulons être maîtres de notre
immigration avec des quotas
d'immigration par origine nous voulons
maîtriser nos flux migratoires nous
voulons aussi davantage de sécurité de
police de justice
bref pour moi libéral que je suis je
souhaite que l'état se concentre sur ses
missions régaliennes
sans oublier l'éducation la santé qui
sont majeurs en revanche dans le domaine
économique est bien moins là aussi je
continue à porter ce qui a été le porte
le projet présidentiel
c'est à dire une volonté de diminuer
très massivement les charges qui pèsent
sur les entreprises pour relancer la
machine économique pour lutter
efficacement contre le chômage et je ne
connais pas d'autres moyens que celui
qui a
c'est opérant dans beaucoup d'autres
pays c'est à dire le libéralisme
économique qui n'est évidemment pas un
libéralisme débridé
c'est une régulation c'est une
protection des plus faibles
mais c'est surtout tirer tout le monde
vers le haut voilà ma droite et je
continuerai à essayer de porter alors là
c'est vrai qu'avec laurent wauquiez on
le sent on est moins enfin sur la partie
économique et sur la partie européenne
on va voir moi j'ai encore qu'on est sur
une une ligne un peu ambiguë mais il a
bon d'en parler on va en parler de
l'europe une ligne ambigu vous l'avez
dit oui justement sur cette question
économique vous dites capitale pour vous
dans l'impression que en tout cas depuis
six mois elle fait pas du tout partie
des priorités de laurent loquet est-ce
que compte tenu de sa le tandem peut se
poursuivre est ce qu'il ne faut pas
juste rompre avec laurent wauquiez
porter vraiment votre discours pour
qu'ils aient une place une véritable
place parce que pour l'instant il n'a
pas le jeu il est marrant comme des
millions de français en mai 2010 est
j'ai eu très peur d'un duel mélenchon le
pen est aujourd'hui si je suis encore
dans la famille de la droite si j'ai
refusé d'aller au gouvernement macron
alors que d'autres ont fait ce choix là
si j'ai vraiment voulu continuer à
soutenir ma famille politique c'est
parce que je pense qu'il est
indispensable de porter une voix
équidistante entre emmanuel macron et
marine le mairie ps je suis passionné la
famille mais nous sommes dans la même
famille mais plus aujourd'hui pécresse
bah oui globalement ces volets on n'a
pas fait le même choix c'est à dire que
valérie que de laurent bocquet
l'occurrence valérie pécresse a fait le
choix de constituer un mouvement qui
s'appelle libre moi j'ai aussi un
mouvement qui s'appelle droit qui pour
justement porter ses idées libérales
mais j'ai fait le choix du rassemblement
au sein de la famille pourquoi parce que
laurent wauquiez me l'a proposé parce
qu'il a voulu afficher ce rassemblement
et je rappelle besoin
besoin de cette musique libéral que vous
incarnez ça a plutôt fonctionné
puisqu'il a recueilli 75 % des suffrages
aujourd'hui
bah écoutez franchement ce serait
incroyable mais peut-être que c'est
possible de se dire tiens on a eu besoin
de quelqu'un pour gagner une élection
pendant trois mois puis après on a moins
besoin
non je lui pose ce sentiment là une fois
encore moi je crois mais peut-être que
d'autres ne font pas ce constat là et
c'est important de le savoir
moi je crois que la droite ne se
reconstruira que si elle est rassemblée
qu'elle marche sur ses deux jambes je
les dis les libéraux et les
conservateurs également ses deux autres
jeunes que sont le régalien et
l'économie c'est cette cesser ce à quoi
gestion analyse car vous pensez que je
m'efforcerai de leur fait et de faire au
maximum de mes possibilités que l'on
invoqué est capable justement sur pause
argument là que vous venez de rappeler
marcher sur ses deux jambes de marcher
sur ses deux jambes et de redresser la
droite
oui oui ce comics vous avez des doutes j
aspire je crains c'est la seule dans son
évolution
sinon nous aurons marine le pen ou
marion maréchal-le pen dont tout le
monde parle aujourd'hui est donc moi je
ne veulent pas de cette porosité avec le
front national
je pense que nous avons un chemin il est
clair il n'est ni proche de macron ni
proche de le pen et c'est ce que je
m'évertuerai à mon niveau de continuer à
porter continué à porter mes convictions
et le fait que cette droite doit être
rassemblée je ne suis pas une diviseuse
j'ai entendu sa gelée lui pas du tout le
fait de dire que ce tract n'a pas été
validé par les instances c'est factuel
et c'est surtout qu'un certain de
fédérations du coup ne l'ont pas utilisé
et c'est pas pour diviser c'est au
contraire se dire comment on travaille
mieux ensemble et collectivement pour
éviter de se retrouver dans cette
situation là une nouvelle fois petite
question de sherlock et ensuite on passe
à la deuxième partie il ya un sujet qui
a beaucoup agité la droite et l'extrême
droite sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs vous avez twitté
déjà hier assez tôt sur le concert de
médine prévu au bataclan
ça fait pas mal réagir notamment du côté
des victimes des associations des
familles sa réaction il ya des réactions
variées il ya des avocats de victimes
qui veulent porter plainte pour faire
interdire le concert mais il ya aussi
l'association one voice qui dit que vous
la droite et l'extrême droite fait de la
manipulation politicienne
écoutez là franchement je répondrai que
c'est pas de la manipulation
politicienne c'est simplement un cri du
coeur moi je vais vous le dire comme ça
en tout cas c'est comme sacrée et effet
mon tweet c'est quand vous voyez que
vous avez quelqu'un qui a revendiqué sur
la couverture d'un disque jihad qui
incarne dans ces propos une certaine
dérive je crois que c'est un problème de
décence en se rappelant que c'est un des
attentats les plus meurtriers que la
france ait connu et c'est simplement la
décence et notamment la mémoire des
victimes
il n'y a pas de récupération
politicienne de quelques natures que ce
soit simplement je trouve que c'est
normal quand on est un personnage public
de pouvoir s'exprimer pour demander tout
simplement l'interdiction de ce concert
ça n'a pas d'autres portés que celle là
pour moi et évidemment les familles des
victimes sont les premières
d'ailleurs à pouvoir s'exprimer avec
toute la légitimité sur cette affaire la
suite de l'épreuve de vérité avec la
deuxième partie on va justement parler
de l'europe où vous avez parlé de
l'ambiguïté de votre parti il ya un
instant avec la question que va vous
poser maintenant paulo bria
[Musique]
quelle stratégie prenez vous pour les
européennes et puis ensuite les
municipales un an plus tard
comment les républicains peuvent-ils
retrouver leur base électorale pour ces
deux échéances
non mais municipal d'abord dans l'ordre
s'étaient d'abord les européens permet
tait parce que je pense que ça c'est
aussi chronologiquement important les
orages en mai 2010 la voilà donc ça
arrive assez vite je reste convaincu que
c'est important que nous soyons dans la
clarté
après c'est mon opinion personnelle je
vous la livre
moi je crois que les électeurs ont
besoin de savoir exactement où ils
seront ceux situés les républiques et il
me semble que là encore nous pouvons
avoir une position trice centrale entre
d'un côté un emmanuel macron dont on
voit qu'il est très fédéraliste qui le
qu'il est favorable à l'élargissement de
l'europe aux balkans qu'il veut un
transfert de souveraineté au niveau
européen qu'il parle d' impôt européen
c'est une vision fédéraliste et de
l'autre l'euroscepticisme ou carrément
le rejet de l'europe qui est incarnée
par les populistes et les extrêmes ou à
une perte nous votre camp une partie de
votre corps je vous propose d'écouter
l'interpellation du politologue pascal
perrineau et s'adresse directement à
vous sur cette question cruciale de
l'europe virginie calmels la question je
voudrais poser à virginie calmels c'est
la suivante au fond est ce que les
républicains même sur cette thématique
européenne sont incapables de trouver un
point d'union et même on peut se dire
que ils adoptent de plus en plus un
discours quand ils dénoncent comme l'a
fait récemment laurent wauquiez l'europe
comme vecteur d'une mondialisation
apatrides
on est certes très proche du discours du
front national mais on est très proche
également peut-être de position du front
national et dans cet espace au fond d'un
nationalisme étroit anti européen
n'y at il pas trop de prétendants le
front national debout la france
dlr qui se radicalise ray alors puis
voilà même ligne il fait il ya un trait
d'union l heure debout la france front
national maintenant ressent et ce n'est
pas ma ligne et aujourd'hui la ligne est
aujourd'hui la ligne de votre nom de
christian jacob et de bruno retailleau
la tribune du figaro deux gars semaine
dernière avec ses propos de
mondialisation des racines et apatrides
était signée par ces trois responsables
de votre parti une fois encore la ligne
pour moi politique des républicains elle
ne doit pas être la ligne d'un homme
mais la ligne d'une famille politique
décidée dans les instances et pour les
pour les européennes ça me semble clé
c'est très important que la ligne
politique donne lieu à une clarification
dans des instances laurent wauquiez l'a
dit le conseil national du 30 juin sera
sur cette thématique des européennes et
de la ligne politique pour les européens
est là justement nazis à menton enfin je
voudrais encore une fois symboliquement
c'est menton ça va être l'immigration
tout ça va toujours tourné autour des
mêmes sujets on a l'impression que c'est
impossible dans le parti ait l'air de
laurent wauquiez de se dégager de ce
sujet là mais le parti a l'air il
comporte des hommes et des femmes de
sensibilités complémentaires il ya des
gaullistes sociaux il ya des libéraux il
ya une droite plus conservatrice il ya
des élus locaux il ya des élus qui sont
des parlementaires vous avez donc
différents enfin pour moi vous avez une
multiplicité de talent et ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'ils s'expriment et qu'il puisse
apporter chacun leur pierre à l'édifice
d'un projet et d'une ligne politique
je pense qu'on va y arriver on aura ce
débat
vous connaissez ma position je suis
résolument provoquer les rouges pour je
souhaite une étude togo république ainsi
la vigne choisi pour les européennes
était la question quel rouge de
l'émission j'ai toujours dit depuis le
départ que moi j'ai accepté la main
tendue de laurent wauquiez que j'étais
pour le rassemblement de notre famille
politique que je ne souhaite pas les
divisions et que je ne veux pas y
participer ça y est les petites phrases
c'est pas moi qui n'en défend les
audiences ouvre on voit bien sur wii
l'ambiguïté sur les on nous y venons et
l'oisiveté ont leur billet pour moi il
est clair qu'il ya effectivement des
choses sur lesquelles je ne serai jamais
confortable et surtout je ne serai pas
une caution
on l'a dit porosité avec le front
national pour moi c'est impossible
le fait d'être des pro européens et pour
moi dans l'adn de la droite et pas
depuis hier
depuis toujours ce qui na qui a rejeté
la construction de l'europe c'est le
front national c'est jean marie le pen
et jacky voté contre le traité de rome
nous nous sommes une famille normalement
pro européenne alors après on entend des
voix parfois dissonante ou plus
souverainiste et fait que mentir et oui
aux aidants de publicans ou julien
aubert parfois mais mais là encore moi
je crois et d'ailleurs on ne les recadre
pas je suis non mais je crois en
l'occurrence que le débat est sain et
qu'il doit se tenir mais je crois aussi
que vis-à-vis des électeurs et vis-à-vis
de ce fameux de ses adhérents mais
au-delà de ça des personnes qui vont
voter aux européennes
on leur doit de la clarté moi j'ai
aspiré à ce qu'on sorte des ambiguïtés
qu'on clarifie le plus vite possible les
lignes parce que je ne suis pas du tout
convaincu que ce soit profitable en plus
d'installer une musique
il n'est pas toujours très
harmonieuse l'indication n'arrive pas ce
qu'elle arrivera un jour est ce que oui
les républicains auront une mise au jour
de l'élection
bah écoutez je le souhaite parce que
sinon je pense que en revanche les
électeurs ne seront pas en rendez vous
savez moi je crois que c'est compliqué
de voter que pour des étiquettes les
gens veulent aussi voter pour des hommes
et des femmes et surtout pour des
projets par les combos par exemple vous
pourriez tête de liste vu tout ce que je
viens de vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que
je serai une caution contraire mais on
fait exclure mais aujourd'hui dans
l'état actuel des choses c'est pour que
je sois tête de liste d'abord il
faudrait que j'ai fait acte de
candidature ce n'est pas le cas ensuite
il faudrait que la ligne soit
parfaitement clarifier ce n'est pas le
cas il faudrait que ce soit fait assez
vite parce que je pense que les
ambiguïtés ne servent pas notre
mouvement politique c'est pas le cas non
plus que vous soyez sûrs d'être encore à
l heure de l'est non michel grossiord
vous voulez me faire dire des choses que
je ne dis pas non non le cuir en oeuvre
au rassemblement et je continue à y
travailler mais ce qui est certain
alors après moi je pense que nous avons
besoin de tous ses talents
nous avons besoin aussi de
renouvellement les jeunes le réclament
les jeunes députés aussi nous avons
besoin d'un collectif c'est pas la faire
d'une personne c'est la sphère d'un
collectif et moi j'ai toujours des la
tête de liste elle doit être cohérente
avec la ligne avec l'équipe avec la
vision avec ce qu'on a envie relations
ne sont moins venus pour que soit vous
je n'ai pas fait acte de candidature
et ça m'amuse quand je jouais dans les
attaques parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attaqués personnelles soudain qui
jaillissent parce que j'ai osé dire oui
contre moi parce que j'ai osé dire que
ce tract n'avait pas été validé par les
instances qui juste rituel est bien dans
ses attaques personnelles livrées à oui
mais elle veut instaurer un rapport de
force pour être tête de liste aux
européennes
une fois encore je le répète je n'ai pas
fait acte de candidature aux européennes
vous connaissez l'âme humaine et des
travers de la politique où vous les
découvrez je les découvre chaque jour
davantage mais j'ai vrai que j'ai eu une
formation accélérée sur les quatre
dernières années de mon engagement je
vous rappelle que moi j'ai passé 20 ans
dans l'entreprise privée donc mairie
flex et mon adn sont plus de
l'entreprise privée que du monde
politique parler des municipales est ce
que l'air peut vraiment refuser la main
tendue de christophe castaner qui est
prêt à des accords donc avec des
sortants de droite avec la république en
marche
c'était d'ailleurs l'objet de notre
première question du sondage opinionway
comme chaque semaine des listes communes
avec la république en marche baby mien
non massif des français dans leur
ensemble 64% ce chiffre qui monte à 60 9
% chez les sympathisants et les airs et
l'ap bien vous êtes en phase écoutez je
crois que ce qui est assez normal c'est
que des adhérents un parti politique
comme les sympathisants ce qu'ils ont
envie c'est qu'on défende nos
convictions nos valeurs sur tous les
scrutins mais tonton déon vous qui avez
dit dans un premier temps on sera pas
regardant sur le qui sera sur la liste
les républicains s'il ya comme ça
quelques marcheurs c'est pas grave
chacun fait ça fait sa tambouille
et puis après il a fait une espèce de
rétro pédalage en disant non surtout pas
de porosité avec la république en marche
comment vous expliquez cette espèce de
volte-face de laurent wauquiez et du
parti des républicains sur la question
je ne sais pas répondre à votre question
est ce qu'il ya vraiment une volte face
j'ai vu la déclaration officielle de
laurent wauquiez qui date de quelques
jours pour dire non il y aura des
candidats et leurs parts ou la prise de
position précédente était moins une
déclaration de leur envier aux pieds que
des propos rapportés en tout cas ce que
je note c'est que la position actuelle
elle n'est pas d'accord avec la
république en marche et ça va être
compliqué parce qu'on a vu l'année
dernière les images d'edouard philippe
le premier ministre ancien élève
moudenc union une chose en train de
s'entendre et on voit bien que ça va
être compliqué pour les mères qui
veulent se faire réélire de dire non à
des alliances à des listes avec des
candidats comment vous allez les
convaincre parce que la bonne politique
d'abord je pense qu'il faut pas être
dupe de cette proposition de christophe
castaner ld noël démontre un fait qu'on
sait déjà c'est que la république en
marche est un parti qui s'est construit
autour et uniquement autour de la
personnalité des manuels macron qu'il
n'ya pas d'ancrage territorial que même
les députés et souvent disent que
finalement retourné en circonscription
bof c'est pas trop leur truc et qu'ils y
passe le moins de temps possible donc on
voit bien qu'on a un parti qui n'a pas
d'ancrage territorial de l'autre côté on
a les républicains qui ont énormément de
sortants puisque vous le savez il y
avait une belle vague bleue aux
municipales et donc nous avons beaucoup
de sortants et par exemple est-ce que
c'est juppé candidat devrait pas prendre
de marcheurs sur sa liste pour avoir la
primature c'est un républicain ça veut
dire que christophe castaner tente
simplement de faire le coucou et de
venir pondre ses oeufs dans le nid des
républicains par de bordeaux maintenant
si on prend des exemples locaux
moi ce qui me semble important c'est de
noter qui s'est passé quand même quelque
chose de tout nouveau ça va être la
première fois qu'il n'ya pas le cumul
des mandats ça veut dire que les maires
ne sont pas des députés maires ou des
sénateurs maires donc qu'est ce qui va
se passer pour beaucoup ils ont pas se
faire élire sur une étiquette politique
d'autant qu'ils ne sont plus connectés à
la politique nationale puisqu'ils n'ont
pas de mandats nationaux
donc ça veut dire que pour beaucoup ils
vont se faire élire sur leurs projets
pour la ville locale et sur leur propre
personnalité et vous le savez dans des
élections municipales
si souvent comme ça que ça se passe mais
quand même le great huguette importe
mémoire et vendez
a bordeaux alain juppé s'il accepte la
main tendue alors qu'est ce que vous
avez fait écouter jeu il faudra poser la
question résidents du parti des
républicains c'est une discussion qu'on
n'a pas eu tous ensemble moi je j'avais
cru comprendre que dans ce cas précis
par exemple à bordeaux il y aurait pas
forcément de candidats les républicains
en face d'alain juppé peut-être que les
choses changeront je n'en sais rien
aujourd'hui c'est que je peux soit
candidat à bordeaux avec l'imprimatur
des républicains je pense que à bordeaux
comme dans beaucoup d'endroits alain
juppé n'a pas besoin d'étiquette pour
être élu sur son nom et qui bon compte
non mais c'est une réalité c'est une
réalité je pense qu'on ne peut pas aller
oui mais vous savez une fois qu il ya la
politique politicienne et puis à des
gens pragmatiques
je fais partie des gens pragmatiques
qu'est ce que voulez que je vous dise
que n'importe où n'importe quand
n'importe comment
oui c'est notre souhait de dire que nous
voulons avoir des candidats aient l'air
notamment les sortants mais on ne peut
pas nier qu'un certain nombre de
personnalités qui ont été maires depuis
longtemps qu'ils sont sortants vont
probablement se présenter sans étiquette
parce que pour l'étiquette importe moins
que leur bilan que leur projet est aussi
que le rassemblement qu'il faut savez il
n'y a pas de liste en france purs et
l'air il ya toujours eu un désaccord à
le croire
avec le modem avec les divers droite
donc et surtout n'oublions jamais les
nonnes encartés moi j'ai été élu à
bordeaux non cartés cadre de l'émission
maintenant allez on change de sujet on
va parler de ceux que vous avez cités à
l'instant il ne s'agit pas d' alain
juppé dans votre question n'est ce pas
sur le non pas d'alain juppé mais des
manuels macro notre président de la
république est il un président de droite
j'ai juste envie de vous faire écouter
ça tout de suite secret du coeur de jean
françois copé sur ce plateau même pas ce
même interviewer médias de mâcon c'est
quand même le président de droite qu'on
n'attendait pas et il faut tout à fait
sincère
personne n'a vu venir emmanuel macron se
disait de gauche et qui depuis qu'il est
élu n'a fait que des mesures que la
droite préconise avec ce soir un accord
entre le sénat l'assemblée nationale
entre la droite le centre et donc la
république en marche pour la réforme de
la sncf
alors effectivement si on prend mesure
après mesure on peut se dire qu'il y a
des choses qu'il a acquis la fête qu'il
emprunte au fond au projet de la droite
tout ou partie il supprime pas
totalement l'isf il en fait que la
moitié
mais ça va quand même dans cette
direction-là la réforme de la sncf
les ordonnances loi travail etc mais
est-ce que ça suffit à définir ce qu'est
un homme ou une femme de droite de mon
point de vue non pourquoi
parce que je pense que la politique ça
se définit par rapport à un tout vous
êtes de droite quand pas uniquement sur
une seule mesure
vous êtes de droite pour moi quand vous
baisser la dépense publique
quand vous baisser les impôts quand vous
avez une politique régaliennes forte
c'est à dire est-ce que emmanuel macron
s'est attaqué au problème de
l'immigration aujourd'hui la réponse est
non est-ce que
la loi immigration elle élargit le
regroupement familial offrait réhausseur
elle a modifié des technicalités mais
sur le délai derniers ont toujours gagné
plusieurs sur le fond son rôle et les
associations le convaincre qu'elle n'est
pas tant de gauche que ça cette loi
zioui je veux dire ça c'est parce que
sous prétexte que la gauche de la gauche
hurle du coup on dit que c'est un projet
de droite mais la droite sociale relève
pas forcément la bouche de lalonde et je
me permettais aucun député de droite n'a
voté cette loi il y a eu un nombre
incroyable d'amendements qui ont été
déposées et le sectarisme
malheureusement de la république en
marche a fait qu'aucun de ces
amendements n'ont été prises en
considération et pour nous c'est une loi
qui va pas dans le bon sens parce
qu'elle est large et le regroupement
familial offrait réhausseur et que
malheureusement elle ne traite pas le
problème de l'immigration 262000 titres
de séjour délivrés l'année dernière un
record depuis 43 ans
c'est bien cela politique d' emmanuel
macron quand on parle de l'asile on sait
que ces cent mille demandes par an et il
n'y a même pas 7 à 15% qui vont être
reconduits à la frontière donc c'est là
encore une façon de laisser sur notre
territoire une immigration illégale
continuez de droite sur le régalien sûr
que nous sur le terrorisme sur le
communautarisme des positions qui sont
très ambigu ce n'est pas clair vous
voyez bien qu'ils emmanuel macron
s'adresse souvent aux différentes
communautés et de ce point de vue là il
n'a pas pris selon moi à bras le corps
un sujet majeur et c'est pour ça qu'ils
emmanuel macron de mon point de vue
n'est pas de droite
et quant au reste tant que vous ne
baissez pas la dépense publique
je suis désolé ça m'agace d'ailleurs
quand dans mon camp on parle d'un macron
libéral ou ultra libérale quand vous
avez 55 % du pib en dépenses afin que la
dépense publique représente 55% du pib
nous ne sommes pas un pays libéral nous
sommes un père et un pays biberonné à la
dépense publique et à l'impôt
edouard philippe dans la campagne
d'alain juppé alors c'est qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est edouard philippe kiki
devenu de gauche ou c'est vous qui êtes
venus face rappelle edouard philippe lui
venait plutôt de chez michel rocard est
globalement il y brille modem et vous
connu chez juppé dès 2002 époque je le
sais vous lisez mon livre qui s'appelle
j'assume
vous verrez pour ce que j'explique c'est
à dire que dans les jus piste alain
juppé avait réussi à faire la synthèse
finalement deux personnes d'hommes et de
femmes qui aujourd'hui certains sont en
marche d'autres sont à giroud
constructif d'autres sont à l'air
d'autres sont encartés il avait fait une
synthèse
mais derrière on voit des lignes
politiques différentes et notamment avec
edouard philippe
j'avais un différend politique sur la
ligne communautariste lui aux isles
euros c'est alors juppé c'est une des
dix noms mais je redis alain juppé
disait l'identité heureuse mais avait
écrit un projet et dont je suis fervente
supportrice encore aujourd'hui qui
s'appelait pour un état fort dans ce
livre pour un état fort c'est une
cohérence totale moi j'ai pas changé
d'idée
c'était des quotas d'immigration c'est l
aménagement de l'aide médicale d'état
c'était le durcissement du regroupement
familial tel que le promu actuellement
les républicains si c'est exactement ça
pour alain juppé il fallait que un des
deux parents soient en situation
régulière pour les républicains
aujourd'hui c'est les deux parents mais
vous voyez que la subtilité est vraiment
très éloignées et le front national
c'est une suppression totale du droit du
donc on est encore sur autre chose mais
si le pour un état fort d'alain juppé
pardon mais c'est vraiment ce à quoi je
crois c'est à dire une politique
régaliennes très ferme et il y avait
tous les exemples avec la construction
de places en prison
la fermeture des mosquées salafistes
toussaint était dans ce projet en
revanche l'identité euros c'était une
autre petite musique qui n'était pas
dans son projet qui était simplement un
élément de langage de campagne et
notamment développé par ses porte
paroles dont edouard philippe il la doit
supporter lui mais nous avions entretien
sarkozy
bien sûr mais la signer lui-même il a
signé lui même pour un état fort qui
était un de ces trois livres
donc ce que je dis c'est que seul alain
juppé a été capable de cette synthèse
entre pour un état fort et l'identité
heureux sur les mines pas encore oui il
faut les faire mais oui mais ferme est
ce que pour vous la l'autriche donne
l'exemple puisqu'ils viennent de décider
d'expulser senti mal oui je pense est un
exemple à suivre
je pense qu'il faut que nous soyons
courageux en disant que nous avons des
personnes qui d'abord moi je suis opposé
au prêche qui ne serait pas en français
pourquoi il faut le faire parce que
c'est un pays qui est dirigée par une
collision de jeu c'est bien extrême
droit je sais bien mais la marche à
suivre
cher michel grossiord c'est pas parce
que des personnes ont des fonds des
choses comment on va dire avec lesquels
on peut trouver des se dire tout
simplement que c'est des bonnes choses
qu'on adhère totalement leur politique
moi j'ai souvent cité avec ce maréchal
non benoît g revient benoît hamon qui
avait une très bonne proposition dans
son projet présidentiel c'est à dire
donner des trimestres de retraite à son
conjoint je trouvais que c'était une
excellente proposition je ne suis pas
hamonistes pour autant c'est pas parce
que monsieur kurz fait quelque chose de
bien c'est à dire fermer des mosquées
salafistes autres fermes et des mosquées
salafistes ou expulser des imams qui
prônerait des excusez moi mais là on est
sur un sujet majeur sont des personnes
qui se retourne contre les intérêts de
la république
les treize jours mettre en jeu mais bien
sûr merveilleux qu'est ce que vous
faites par rapport aux mets sont latents
ou non au médicament je vous assure je
vous assure que ça voyez c'est pour ça
que je suis de droite et c'est pour ça
que je continuerai à me battre en
politique pour essayer qu'on arrête de
confondre tout et n'importe quoi je
réponds aux cons osent mais pardon qu'on
ose confondre des imams qui prêchent
parfois la haine qu'ils retournent des
personnes sur notre sol contre la
république qui
sont à l'origine d'attentats commis à
l'armé blanche et qu'on puisse comparer
avec des messes en latin
excusez-moi différence c'est qu'en latin
pardon d'abord c'est facile à traduire
vous avez peut-être fait du latin dans
votre jeunesse moi j'en ai fait on n'a
aucun problème à savoir que toutes les
messes en latin d'abord ce n'est pas les
prêches ce sont les messes et que les
messes en latin on sait ce qu'il ya
dedans et elle ne prône rien d'autre que
dieu est amour
là on est en train de comparer des
choses qui sont de mon point de vue
incomparable
et oui je suis pour la fermeture des
mosquées salafistes et pour imposer les
prés champs français justement pour
éviter cette le fait que ceux de sur le
sol français il y ait cette utilisation
de la religion contre la république et
je suis également pour qu'il n'y ait
aucun financement par des puissances
étrangères des mosquées en france vous
vouliez parler de madame marion maréchal
puisque certains de vos anciens proches
se disent qu'il faut entamer le dialogue
avec elle alors et leucate et des jeunes
avec calme et là en l'occurrence
l'ancien responsable des jeunes avec l
mels avait fait une tribune
deux mois avant dans le nouvel obs de
mémoire pour dire pourquoi il fallait
surtout pas d'alliance entre l air et le
front national et marion maréchal-le pen
au bout visiblement il a changé d'avis
moi j'en ai pas changé pour moi
là encore elle est sympathique elle est
jeune elle est jolie mais il faut quand
même bien regarder ce que sont ces
valeurs ce qu'est le projet d'abord le
projet du front national jeu j'aime bien
le rappeler parce que des gens ont l'air
de l'oublier c'est un projet économique
d'extrême gauche c'est le même que jean
luc mélenchon la retraite à 60 ans 150
milliards de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires
c'est marion maréchal le plus sur une
ligne libérale marion maréchal on
connaît pas notre projet voilà donc tout
le monde échafaudant fait qui pourrait
être sa vision en revanche sur une ligne
sociétal qui est particulièrement
réactionnaire avec des positions sur
l'île et g
et où sur le planning familial sipa la
société dans laquelle j'ai envie de
vivre en moi et une fois encore pour moi
on n'est pas sur le même projet ni de
société ni le même projet politique et
ceux qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs du front national ils ont le
front national ils ont déjà voté
probablement longtemps pour le front
national
moi je reste convaincu qu'on a des
sympathisants de droite qui attendent de
nous justement de porter autre chose que
ce que porte le front national merci
verviers km vous avez démontré manquez
pas de mordant ça va être intéressant à
suivre évidemment dans vos réunions
internes à l air y en a une demain qui
vous attend vous serez peut-être sur la
sellette merci merci beaucoup paul
merci merci beaucoup charlotte bonsoir à
tous à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]